اهلا بكم ترتفع سخونه المواجهه بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده بشان الوضع في شبه
جزيره القرم بعد قيام واشنطن بفرض عقوبات
محدوده على موسكو التي ردت بانها لن تقبل
سياسه التهديد والوعيد نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين ما هي اوراق الضغط المتاحه لدى كل
من موسكو وواشنطن في ازمه
القرم وما هي فرص التوصل الى تسويه
دبلوماسيه تضمن الحفاظ على مصالح كل
الاطراف
وكان اوكرانيا صارت رقعه الشطرنج التي
تدور عليها منافسات القوى الكبرى لفرض
النفوذ في شرق اوروبا لكن المربع الاكثر
سخونه الان هو شبه جزيره القرم هناك تحاول
روسيا فرض الامر الواقع عسكريا بجنودها
وسياسيا باستفتاء لتقرير المصير بينما
تسعى واشنطن لخفض سقف طموحات الدب الروسي
قدر الامكان بالضغط السياسي والعقوبات
الاقتصاديه ورغم حاله الجمود الراهنه
مازال الجميع يتحدث عن ضروره تغليب الحلول
الدبلوماسيه عن
سواه الى البحر الاسود تتجه المدمره
الامريكيه تراكستان بصواريخها الموجهه لكن
ذلك كما حرص الجيش الامريكي لا صله له
بالازمه الاوكرانيه بل بتدريبات مقرره مع
البحرين الرومانيه
والبلغار على الضفه الاخرى القوات روسيه
موجوده على الارض لديهم هناك اسطول البحر
الاسود ولهم قوات اخرى دخلت بالفعل شبه
جزيره القرن واكثر من ذلك لديهم مواطنون
من اصول روسيه هناك وغطاء قانوني للتدخل
العسكري لو ارادوا بوتين مخول من مجلس
الاتحاد الروسي في هذا الشان اذا رغب
واراد كل ذلك براي محللين لا يعني ان ثمه
مواجهه عسكريه في الافق لقد تغير الزمن
فاو باما ليس قادما من ازمنه الحرب
البارده ولا من صفوف الجمهوريين ومنذ
وصوله الى البيت الابيض قامت استراتيجيته
على الانسحاب للمزيد من التورط في الازمات
واذا حدث فلل الدبلوماسيه الكلمه الاولى
وهو ما حدث ويحدث فعلا في الازمه
الاوكرانيه لقد امر بفرض عقوبات على
المسؤولين عن التدخل الروسي وتشمل حظر
السفر وتجميد ارصده في الولايات المتحده
وعلى خطاه يسير الاتحاد الاوروبي الشريك
الاقتصادي الاكبر
لروسيا تمتلك موسكو في المقابل ورقه الغاز
منعا او سماحا للرد على العقوبات وتلك
معادله يؤذي فيها كل طرف الطرف الاخر
لكنها ليست كافيه لاجباره على الرضوخ
ولديها ما هو اهم بنيه حكم تمنحها الازمه
من الغرب شعب
اكبر في الداخل في ظل تزايد المشاعر
القوميه في روسيا بالتوازي فان وطاه اي
عقوبات على روسيا تظل اقل حده مما لو فرضت
على دول اخرى فالاقتصاد الروسي حديث عهد
بالانفتاح على الغرب ولم يعرف طيله الحقبه
السوفيتيه اقتصاد السوق بل اداره الدوله
اما سياسيا فان ما يعتبر انسحابا امريكيا
من العالم منح موسكو دورا يتعاظم في زمات
ما يجعل تكاليف اي صراع معها اكبر مما
يعتقد ويقصر التعامل معها في اطار الصفقات
للمواجهات
معنا في هذه الحلقه من موسكو الدكتور زياد
سبسبي نائب رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه
في المجلس الفيدرالي الروسي ومن واشنطن
سيث كروس كروبس كبير الباحثين في معهد
هادسون ومساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي سابقا
اهلا بضيفنا نبدا من موسكو ودكتور زياد
سبسبي على ماذا تعتمد موسكو في ابداء كل
هذا التشدد في موضوع جزيره شبه جزيره
القرم كما يوصف الموقف
الروسي اولا تعتمد روسيا في موقفها هذا
على البعد الاستراتيجي لجمهوريه اوكرانيا
والعلاقات التاريخيه التي تربط الدولتين
وايضا تعتمد على وجود اكثر من 2 مليون
نسمه مواطنين من اصول روسيا بقوا بعد
انحلال الاتحاد السوفيتي في اوكرانيا
اليوم روسيا الاتحاديه لم تعلن الحرب على
احد ولا هي قادمه ل لتهيئه اي حرب ضد
اوكرانيا ونحن دائما نقول بان ما يجمعنا
باوكرانيا هو اي علاقات قويه
اي يصل تاريخ تاريخها الى الاف السنين
فاليوم الوسائل الاعلام في اوروبا وفي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تضخم من حجم
المشكله الاوكرانيه ومدى علاقه وتدخل
روسيا في هذه المشكله او في هذا النزاع
الداخلي الذي حصل في الفتره الاخيره في
اوكرانيا يعني اذا اذا كانت موسكو تعتمد
على هذا الواقع الجغرافي والتاريخي لنسال
ضيفنا السيد سيث كروبس على ماذا تعتمد
واشنطن في سعيها لاثناء
موسكو عن موقفها في جزيره
القرم يتعلق بما تقوم به امريكا سؤالي على
ماذا تعول ما هي اوراق القوه التي لدى
واشنطن لثني موسكو عما تقوم به الان في
جزيره القرم شبه جزيره
القرم ما قامت به امريكا حتى الساعه
يتمثل
في اصدار عقوبات محدوده وكذلك قامت امريكا
بمجموعه احتجاجات دبلوماسيه وكذلك قامت
باجراء محادثات بين الرئيس اوباما والسيد
بوتن كانت هناك قوات جويه محدوده تم
ارسالها الى دول الناتو الصديقه في اوروبا
وتم ارسال مدمره كذلك الى البحر الاسود من
ناحيه اخرى فان روسيا قامت باجتياح القرم
وقامت بتاسيس
وانشاء سلطه لديها وتابعه لها هناك وهي
ستقوم بتنظيم
انتخابات تحت النار لتتمكن من ان تكون
نتيجه هذه الانتخابات في صالحها وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث عن صوره غير متوازنه عما قامت
به روسيا والمتمثل في نشر قواتها على
الارض وما قامت به امريكا والمتمثل في فرض
عقوبات محدوده وكذلك القيام ببعض
الاحتجاجات الدبلوماسيه نعم سيد كرسي انت
وصفت العقوبات بانها محدوده ووصفت ال
ارسال القوات العسكريه بانه
محدود هذا الوضع المحدود يمكن ان يؤثر في
موسكو هللا اعدت الجزء الاخير من السؤال
يعني اسف يعني العقوبات وصفتها بانها
محدوده والقوات العسكريه التي تحركت الى
اوروبا وصفتها بانها محدوده
طالما هي محدوده هل يمكن ان تؤثر في
موسكو لا يبدو ذلك مرجحا على
الاطلاق اذا في هذه الحاله دكتور زياد
سبسبي انتم عندما تحدثتم قبل قليل عن
اوراق القوه لدى موسكو اشرت الى البعد
التاريخي والى روابط
اواصر العلاقه بين روسيا وبين شبه جزيره
القرم ولكن الا يكفي هذا يكفي بتقديرك حتى
يقع تفهم الموقف الروسي وفرضه
في لدى الراي العام
الدولي اولا بعد انتهاء الحرب البارده
التي كانت ما بين المعسكر الغربي والاتحاد
السوفيتي روسيا استطاعت ان تتخلص من
العقده النفسيه
التي عاشتها ورافقتها على مدى 70 او اكثر
من من 70 عاما للاسف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى الان لم تتخلص من هذه
العقده والى الان تنصب نفسها عرابا ومديرا
وكم رجل يريد ان يدير الع العالم ويدير
الازمات في العالم على حسب تفهمه وبما
يتناسب مع مصالحه القوميه ومصالحه الامنيه
هذا اولا ثانيا عندما نتكلم نحن اليوم عن
اوكرانيا وعن جزيره القرم اود شبه جزيره
القرم اود ان انبه وخاصه ضيفي ضيفكم الع
العزيز الذي قال بانه كان هنالك اجتياح
للجيش الروسي اود ان انبه لم يدخل ولا
جنديا واحدا من الاراضي الروسيه الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه الجنود الروسي
المتواجدون اليوم في اوكرانيا متواجدون
بشكل شرعي وقانوني بناء على معاهده تم توق
ها ما بين روسيا الاتحاديه وبين الحكومه
الاوكرانيه الشرعيه وبما ان اليوم لم يكن
ه لم يعد هنالك تواجدا لسلطه شرعيه منتخبه
يمكن ان تمثل رئيس الدوله او تمثل
البرلمان الاوكراني لا يمكن لنا اليوم ان
نتكلم عن اي اجراءات قانونيه من جهات
السلطات المحليه التي وصلت الى الحكم عن
طريق ليس انقلابا عسكريا وانما عن طريق
انقلابا ارهابيا ارغمت عليه السلطه
القانونيه المتواجده في
اوكرانيا اسمح اسمح لي فقط دكتور سبسبي
اسمح لي فقط طالما اشرت الى هذه
القوات كثير من المحللين يعتقدون بان نقطه
القوه الرئيسيه لدى موسكو هي اصلا استعمال
القوه او التهديد بها او التلويح بها من
خلال هذه القوات وبالتالي هنا التساؤل ان
كان للامريكيين عقده اليس للروس ايضا عقده
وهي عقده الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق ونوازع
الهيمنه التي ما زالت لدى موسكو
ا روسيا لا ترمي الحجار في بيوت الجيران
كما تفعل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نحن
اذا تذكرنا في عام
1999 السيد جورج بوش اعلن عن غزو بانما
فقط لانه كان لدى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اخبار ي يشك بها بانه يمكن عن
طريق بانما وخاصه الجنرال امانويل انه
يمكن ان يكون هنالك عمليات تهريب للمخدرات
من بانما الى امريكا وكان سببا للغزو نحن
نكرر ونؤكد مره اخرى وقد اكد السيد بوتين
روسيا لا تريد ولا تفكر بقيام اي عمل
عدواني تجاه اوكرانيا الشعب الاوكراني هو
شعب شقيق وليس شعب صديق شعب واحد هو الشعب
السلافي وحتى روسيا كان بدايتها او هي
كانت تكمله لاوكرانيا كما كما كان كانت
تسمى كيف الروسيه وحتى جزيره شبه جزيره
القرم تاريخيا لم تكن في لحظه من اللحظات
في تعداد اوكرانيا واوكرانيا كانت على حقب
كبير كبيره من الزمن كانت في عداد روسيا
الاتحاديه روسيا الاتحاديه اليوم لا تعتبر
نفسها دوله امبراطوريه وليس لها
اي طمع في تواجد اضافي في اوكرانيا ولكن
اليوم القياده الروسيه والشعب الروسي مجبر
ومرغم وامامه التزامات اخلاقيه امام الروس
الذي يتجاوز ط نتحدث عن التزامات
الاخلاقيه اسمح لي دكتور سبسبي ان اسال
ضيفنا الامريكي الجانب الاخلاقي سيد كروسي
هل هو اضعف اوراق الولايات المتحده كما
يقول ضيفنا ربما واشنطن ليست في وضع يسمح
لها بالضغط القوي على موسكو في هذه النقطه
لان لديها سوابق في مسائل ونزاعات دوليه
اخرى لم يكن فيها الموقف الاخلاقي او
القانوني للولايات المتحده موقفا
قويا اذا كان ضيفك في موسكو يحاول ان يخبر
مشاهدي بان صال شبه جزيره القرم من
جمهوريه اوكرانيا يتماشى مع اراده الشعب
الاوكراني فيمكننا ان نخبركم بان ذلك محض
هراء لا معنى له اما فيما يتعلق بالمشاكل
النفسيه التي تم التحدث عنها فليس هناك
مثل هذه المشاكل النفسيه في هذا السياق
وبالاخص في ما يتعلق بامريكا فنحن هنا لا
نتحدث عن قضايا نفسيه وانما نتحدث عن نظام
دولي اذا كان هذا هو العالم الذي توجد فيه
دوله مستقله تتعرض لاجتياح من دوله اخرى
تستخدم قواتها وتسيطر على ارضها هذا هو
السؤال الذي كان موجودا في الشيشان وفي
الحاله الروسيه تحديدا ولا يتعلق ابدا
بالعقد النفسيه نعم سيد
كروسي هناك من يعتقد ايضا بان نقاط القوه
لدى الموقف الروسي اقوى حتى الاعتبارات
اقتصاديه موضوع الغاز بامكان موسكو ان
تقطع الغاز عن اوكرانيا وبالتالي عن
اوروبا السلاح الاقتصادي الا تراه في
موسكو اقوى مما لدى واشنطن بتهديدها بفرض
عقوبات هناك قضايا عديده تستطيع امريكا ان
تقوم بها من اجل ان تقلص وتخفف الضغط على
اوروبا الغربيه و من اجل ان لا تكون
معتمده على النفط والغاز الروسي اول هذه
القضايا تتمثل في السماح ببيع النفط
الامريكي والغاز الطبيعي الامريكي الى
الدول التي لا تربطنا بها اتفاقات تجاره
حره وهذه تشمل دول عديده في اوروبا ذلك
سيخفف اعتمادها على النفط والغاز الروسيين
امر اخر يمكننا ان نقوم به يتمثل في تقديم
ضمانات امنيه في منطقه شرقيه البحر الابيض
المتوسط ل ان
تكون الا استكشافات الغاز الغاز على
القباله السواحل الاسرائيليه وال قبرصيه
يمكن ان تتدفق الى اوروبا لتقلل اعتمادها
على النفط والغاز الروسيين واملوا ان تقوم
امريكا بذلك ومع ذلك ورغم التوتر القائم
الان فيما يتعلق بشبه جزيره القرم الكل ما
زال مع ذلك يراهن عن امكانيه التوصل الى
تسويه دبلوماسيه بين الطرفي هذا ما سنحاول
ان نقف عنده بعد الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها اوراق الضغط
المتاحه لدى كل من موسكو وواشنطن في
خلافهما بشان مستقبل شبه جزيره القرم
دكتور زياد
سبسبي رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني اعتبر بان
على موسكو ان تقوم بالخطوه الاولى في اي
تسويه عليها ان تقوم بخطوه الى الوراء
وتتراجع ان كانت حريصه على الافق
الدبلوماسي للتسويه هل هذا ممكن
ا طبعا ممكن ويجب ان يتم هذا الامر ولكن
يجب ان نعيد الاحداث في اوكرانيا الى
مجالها الطبيعي اي اعاده
الوضع الان الفوضوي الى وضع قانوني شرعي
في اوكرانيا ونحن على علم بان هنالك كان
معاهده قد وقعت بحضور وبتوقيع وزراء
الخارجيه بولونيا والمانيا وفرنسا نحن
نقول يجب ان يعاد كل شيء الى الى الحظيره
القانونيه والشرعيه لكي يكون هنالك معالجه
صحيحه للازمه الاوكرانيه ضيف يعني معنى
ذلك دكتور معنى ذلك انه اذا عادت عجله
الاحداث في اوكرانيا الى ما كانت عليه
موسكو مستعده بدورها ان تراجع خطواتها
السابقه الى ما نعم الى ما كانت عليه قبل
21 فبراير اي نحن نقول يجب ان يكون هنالك
تنفيذا حرفيا للاتفاقيه التي وقعها
يانكوفيتش وبهذه الاتفاقيه اعترف بانه هو
سيق سيقوم بنفسه بالتحضير واجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المبكره والبرلمانيه
المبكره ولكن اود ان اقول بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يجب ان يكون اليوم ليست
اول دوله التي تتكلم عن تنفيذ القانون
الدولي لديها خبره جيده في الاحداث في
ليبيا وفي يوغسلافيا وفي افغانستان وفي
العراق فلا اذا كان في مثل يقول اذا كان
بيتك من زجاج لا تضرب الاخرين بالاحجار
نعم فيما يتعلق بالتسويه فيما يتعلق
بالتسويه الممكنه سيد نعم فيما يتعلق
ساعود اليك فيما يتعلق بالتسويه
الممكنه سيد سث
كروبس اوباما تحدث مع بوتين لمده ساعه عبر
الهاتف ولم يتم التوصل الى شيء هل تعتقد
بان السيناريو الذي عرضها عرضه ضيفنا من
موسكو قابل ان يكون هو التسويه
الممكنه
اورو اعيد السؤال على امل ان ان يصل الصوت
ضيفنا الامريكي ما عرضه ضيفنا لا واضح من
اشاره الراس ان يس
اوكي ما عرضه ضيفنا من من موسكو هل يمكن
ان يكون اساسا لتسويه محتمله بين موسكو
وواشنطن فيما يتعلق بشبه جزيره
القرم اذا كان بوتن مستعد للتخلي عن
المكاسب غير الشرعيه التي احرزها في القرم
ذلك سيكون ممكن لكنه لن يحدث ل لكن فيما
يتعلق بما يقوله ضيفكم في موسكو فمن ناحيه
هو يتحدث عن اسئله يه ومن ناحيه اخرى
يتحدث عن اسئله قانونيه فهو لا كحديثه ليس
مرضيا في الناحيتين وعلى وجه التحديد فيما
يتعلق بالبعد الاخلاقي فهل تصرفت روسيا من
ناحيه اخلاقيه من خلال دعمها لنظام الاسد
في روسيا حيث قتل مئات الالاف من الاشخاص
هناك هل تصرفت روسيا بشكل اخلاقي في
تعاملها مع المسلمين في الشيشان لا اعتقد
ان حكومه ضيفك لديها ارضيه اخلاقيه في هذا
نقاش نعم المساله جديره بال بالتوقف عندها
ولكن حتى نتقدم في هذا العنصر الخاص بفرص
التسويه اسال الكتور سبسبي الان يوجد
مراقبون من منظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا حاولت الدخول الى شبه جزيره القرم
ومنعت من قبل الجنود هناك الم تكن هذه
فرصه لاعطاء مدى
لاستكشاف فرص التوصل الى تسويه على الارض
يجب ان يعود الامر الى وضعه الطبيعي قبل
21 فبراير اولا ثانيا لم تمنع من قبل جنود
وانما منعت من قبل ناشطين مؤيدين للحكومه
المحليه في شبه جزيره القرم
ا لا اود ان اعلق عن كلام الضيف ولكن لا
يمكن ان اقول بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ايضا كان لها يدا بيضاء بين
قوسين في الاحداث التي تجري اليوم في
سوريا والتي جرت في الشيشان والتي تجري
ايضا في افغانستان والعراق لا يوجد اي
تناقض اخلاقي او قانوني ولكن كموظف في
وزاره الدفاع وتقع عليه ايضا
شخ مسؤوليه محدده يمكن الان يريد ان يبرئ
نعيد الى ولكن اسمح لي دكتور اسمح لي
دكتور اسمح لي دكتور سبسبي يعني الا يخشى
بان موسكو باصراره على الموقف الذي تقفه
الان قد تتعرض الى عزله دوليه في المستقبل
اذا لم يتم التوصل الى
تسويه موسكو تقول نحن مع تنفيذ القانون
الدولي الذي يتكلم عنه الضيف نحن مع تنفيذ
القانون حتى الاوكراني المحلي الذي يتكلم
عنه الاوكرانيين وما يسمى بالمعارضه
بالنسبه للغاز تنويه قليل عر ثواني روسيا
لن تمنع الغاز عن اوكرانيا ولكن هذا
الموضوع تجاري يجب ان تلتزم اوكرانيا بدفع
ما عليها من اموال ثمن دفع الغاز لا يوجد
اي شيء مجانا اليوم في العالم الى هذه
الساعه بلغ دين اوكرانيا 2 مليار دولار
فقط بثمن الغاز فاذا تم قطع الغاز لاسباب
اقتصاديه لا يجب علينا ان نحول الموضوع
الاقتصادي الى موضوع سياسي نحن مع الحل
الشرعي وما يريده الشعب الاوكراني في كل
اجزائه ليس فقط في كيف وحوالي ساحه
الميدان التي يتزعمها ارهابيون متواجدون
وخاصه اذكر الضيف بان ياروش مسؤول الكبير
في المعارضه توجه برساله الى دكو ومارف
مسؤول كبير الارهابيين في شمال القوقاز
والذي ادخلته الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في قائمه الارهاب والمطلوبين عالميا طلب
منه ان يقدم مساعده
عسكريه طالما نحن نتحدث عن فرص التسويه
اسمح لي فقط بالمقاطعه حتى انهي مع السيد
سذ
كروسي بغض النظر عن ما قاله ضيفنا الان لا
نريد ان ان نسجل في نهايه البرنامج سيد
كروسي هل تعتقد بان هناك طرف ما سواء
الامم المتحده او اوروبا او غيرها قادره
على ان تلعب دور في تسويه محتمله بين
موسكو وواشنطن فيما يتعلق بهذه
القضيه اعتقد بان الطريقه الوحيده
التي ستقوم بها روسيا بتغيير وايقاف
اجتياحها تتمثل فيما اذا تراجع السيد بوتن
عن موقفه والطريقه الوحيده التي سيحدث بها
ذلك هو اذا غير سلوكه بشكل كبير او اذا
تمكن الغرب من فرض عقوبات ناجعه اي شيء دا
ذلك سيجعلنا نقبل الوضع كما هو وكما
حددتها القوات الروسيه على الارض وبالتالي
الامر نطن بالغرب اذا كان هذا الغرب يقوم
باستجابه وقويه واذا كان حاسما في
استجابته فستكون هناك فرصه في حل هذه
الازمه ما اقصده بحل هذه الازمه وهذا
الوضع هو ان نسمح للشعب الاوكراني بان
يتخذ قراره بنفسه دون ان توجه له البنادق
على راسه هذا ما يفعله بوتن اي انه يضع
الشعب الاوكرانيه تحت ضغط تهديد السلا
وبتالي يجب ان نمكن الشعب الاكراني من
تقرير مصيره بنفسه شكرا جزيلا لضيفنا من
واشنطن س كروبي كبير الباحثين في معهد
هادسون ومساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من موسكو الدكتور
زياد سبسبي نائب رئيس لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه في المجلس الفيدرالي الروسي بهذا
نصل مشاهدينا الكرام الى نهايه هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر غدا باذن الله
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد استودعكم
الله
ا